alors avec nous donc luc plamondon c'est
avec lui qu'on va commencer qui est
l'auteur de starmania pour la musique
c'est michel berger et vous êtes co
scénariste avec michel serrault n'est
qu'au matin vincennes en ce moment voilà
alors re starmania à paris cette fois
c'est au théâtre de paris dix ans après
le palais des congrès qu'est ce que ça
change au privilégiera est ce que les la
différence des deux théâtres que le
théâtre de paris beaucoup plus petits
lacets des plus petites vous a obligé à
des modifications a de toute façon c'est
une nouvelle mise en scène complètement
mais là on le remonte dans un théâtre
dans un vrai théâtre comme les comme les
musicals de broadway ou de londres se
tait à 2000 places mais réitère
d'ailleurs est alors qu'au départ au
palais des congrès en avaient fait un
grand show rock avec beaucoup d'effets
de beaucoup là c'est une mise en scène
quand même spectaculaire on ne sait pas
si c'est plus épurée mais ça reste un
spectacle alors luc plamondon en 1969 il
y avait eu r c'était sous les pavés la
plage en 79 ya eu starmania c'est là la
plage était un peu pollué et alors
starmania 88 fait quoi ça pouvait donner
une définition c'est la vie quotidienne
d'aujourd'hui je pense c'était futuriste
et 10 ha mais finalement on se rend
compte que ils peuvent jouer le
spectacle maintenant pratiquement 100 et
je parle des chanteurs les chanteurs on
les a choisi d'abord parce qu'ils
correspondent beaucoup à leurs
personnages
mais on n'a pas de costumes futuristes
ou le sang et des costumes qui pourrait
être d'aujourd'hui est bon mais ne
police la capitale de l'occident ça
existe presque déjà c'est la grande
ville moderne quoi parlez nous un peu de
ses interprètes parce que quand même
succédé à france gall fabienne thibeault
diane dufresne c'est pas facile mais
nous disons après ben écoutez il faut
d'abord dire que fabienne thibeault
daniel balavoine étaient des inconnus
quand on les a choisis à 10 ans pour
jouer dans starmania diane dufresne et
était un peu connu et france gall qu
était en train de devenir une grande
vedette mais bon
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on va lancer
encore un bon moral entre autres mais
bon il ya martine st clair et on faisait
deux québécoises que vous connaissez pas
en france renaud hensen qui est un jeune
chanteur français formidable ya les
frères gros des deux québécois qui joue
les deux frères ennemis dans ce
spectacle fait qu'ils changent de si
vous le voulez bien va se faire une idée
puisque en à filmer les répétitions
alors les voici
selon adam et ans
ce jour on est tranquille j'ai connu
temps
par chance de prouver aux importuns
alors
quand on a eu envie que tu te rends dans
la vie on fait ce qu'on veut
passons j'aurais voulu être merci
ce fonds
sur l'appui
avant terme
et
alors moi j'avais aimé starmania il ya
neuf ans j'y suis allé j'ai acheté le
disque
qu'est ce qui pourrait motiver
aujourd'hui d'y retourner est ce qu est
ce que vous n'avez pas pareil est ce que
vous aviez compris l'histoire il ya dix
ans il ya dix ans les gens sortaient
redisant les chansons ça formidable
c'était respecte mais on comprend rien à
l'histoire
alors là cette fois ci d'abord entre
temps la remontée deux fois au québec en
81 à 86 et à chaque fois on avait
travaillé et maintenant ça se lit comme
un temps machine quoi on suit l'histoire
comme un film et et les chansons sont
toujours là bien sûr mais je crois qu
est ce qui peut vous motiver c'est de
venir comprend de quoi sa part joué la
première partie j'ai vu maintenant je
vais comprendre dallas leur appui tous
les jeunes bien sûr qui a 10 ans comme
les chanteurs d'ailleurs devais avoir 10
ans ben ils peuvent aujourd'hui venir
voir starmania et découvrir ce que leur
papa leur ont raconté à ce propos merci
luc plamondon c'est à partir du 15
septembre au théâtre de paris à paris